Now let's move on to a slightly more complicated question:
out of all the families with two kids--
with at least 1 boy, born on a Tuesday--
what's the probability of two boys?
Now, you might think that the answer should be the same--
it should still be 1/3 because why does Tuesday matter?
After all, the kid's gotta be born sometime
and if it happens to be Tuesday,
why would that be any different than any other day?
So is it 1/3?
Well, as Gottfried Leibniz said, "Let us calculate."
So we have the technology to model that.
First, a random variable for day of the week-_
and I had to fool around with the capitalization there,
to make sure that we have 7 distinct letters:
Sunday, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday--
plus ample space of twokidsbday,
one kid with their day of birth;
the second kid, with their day of birth.
What does that look like? Well, it's this huge thing
of (2 X 7 X 2 X 7) entries.
The first one: Boy born on Sunday;
boy born on Sunday, all the way through
to the last one: girl born on Saturday, girl born on Saturday.
Then a boy born on Tuesday is all the elements of this,
where "BT" appears is in the string.
So either "BT" will be the first 2 characters or the last 2 characters.
And now we're finally at the point
where we can say: given at least 1 boy_tuesday,
what's the probability of two_boys?
And before I show the results,
I'm going to ask you what you think it is.
You could follow along, either with pencil and paper
or do the computation or just think it out in your head.
So Enter as a fraction. If you think it's 1/3,
put a 1 here and a 3 here--or whatever.